peeping tom et à orléans ce soir une
compagnie de danse venus de bruxelles
qui présente un univers fantastique
le spectacle que l'on va découvrir
nourri son imaginaire du lien avec le
spectateur on y va des jeux de jambes
trébuchant décor qui se contorsionne
dans un délire orchestré avec précision
à louer c'est la danse d'un monde où
tout est en location l'histoire de
l'artiste en proie au doute
c'est un écrivain sait qui est qui est
là qui écrit son histoire et qui doutent
de son défunt qui doute ce ne sont pas
de son histoire mais qui doutent de sa
d'elle-même en fait des cper de ces
entrants de crise entendent donc elle et
elle raconte une histoire c'est
l'histoire d'une famille d'une mezzo
soprano qui qui perd petit à petit sa
voix chantante en science toute sa vie
et chanter le public élèves et la fleur
je suis fâché d'elle et on joue aussi le
jeu en fin juin quand elle vient
dans la maison on joue qu'elle était
d'un auditions et j ai commencé telle
audition à 10h je suis la meilleure
j'ai ce qu on aime bien l'hyperréalisme
on aime bien avoir un décor
hyperréaliste de tonnes de mettre les
caractères dans un cadre très réaliste
après après c'est un spectacle de danse
le spectacle est inspiré d'une histoire
vraie est celle d'un théâtre en
argentine vendus et transformés en
centre commercial
quelle est la place de la culture en
temps de crise
une question lancinante à laquelle la
compagnie répond avec un talent
époustouflant
izia cola formations venues du soudan
est en ce moment en tournée dans toute
la france
de la chanson folk à découvrir en
première partie de la rue kétanou à
sancerre ce samedi je voudrais faire le
tour de la terre être fiers ne vous
disputez pas il y aura du malheur pour
tout le monde pour pierre tilman la
parole c'est de l'art une parole
multiforme qui prend un sens nouveau au
regard de l'actualité la parole matière
de la liberté
l'exposition du plasticien poète est à
découvrir jusqu'au 2 février
musique après orléans splendide ça
arrive à tour la pièce de théâtre de
jean genet interprété en anglais
un texte fort noir et subversif le poème
d'une mythologie du crime américain à ne
pas manquer
c'est là que j'ai commencé à 30 a sonné
ça des pdg du cac 40 et quelles mesures
destinées à en épouser parce que
finalement footballeur c'est juste
quelqu'un comment épouser un
milliardaire c'est le titre de ce one
woman show satirique à découvrir à
chartres voilà pour ce qui fait
l'actualité culturelle dans notre région
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
de nouvelles idées de sorties bon week
end